effondre une pétition demandant votre
démission au québec on se souvient du
maire de mascouche richard marcotte et
de la mauvaise réputation dont il avait
affublé sa ville qu'il a dirigée de 1991
à 2012 à l'époque le député de la région
avaient dénoncé l'attribution de
certains contrats à des amis du maire
l'élu du parti québécois avait subi les
menaces d'un entrepreneur qui a ensuite
été arrêté et emprisonné
aujourd'hui le nouveau maire de
mascouche c'est lui guillaume tremblay
il a été élu en 2013 et réélu en 2017
lors de la première élection clairement
que l'objectif était justement à suite à
la commission charbonneau de rentrer à
la ville puis de faire un grand ménage
de juin 2012 à l'automne 2014 la
commission présidée par la juge france
charbonneau a été roger environ 300
témoins dont certains ont fortement
marqué les esprits du plus long match et
n'est que celui pourquoi ce que c'est je
connais sable vraiment c'est l'argent
que vous venez de mettre dans vos bras
avec monsieur invictus d'exact oui 3%
des contre allées aux partis politiques
du maire tremblay aucun frais à la
charge en demandant
de démontrer des stratagèmes pour niveau
municipal je pense que cette
démonstration lors le fait est bon qui
m'écrivait des courriels live interrogé
puis film z devriez poser cette question
look finissait pas son nom par un génial
on va le laisser y ait cet argent
comptant le savent
au financement diverses politiques je
n'ai jamais fait
d'aveux de la main volontaire que ce
soit et vous n'avez je ne suis pas
nerveux posée parce qu'on a un nom
italien qui ont fait partie de ce que
les marques indien ce que là comme ça ça
benoît fait et le prix certains pans de
l' enquête policière qui était qui était
commencée qui marchait et elle s'en est
servi pour des voiliers voici la
corruption qui a la balle par la suite
les procès à laval nous entrons du maire
vaillancourt à l'époque on continue il a
été condamné de même que plusieurs de
ses ses acolytes à ce niveau là là comme
ça ça ne nous a pas apporté quelque
chose de neuf pour les tribunaux ont
contribué exclusivement pour la
démocratie ou encore mais aussi pour eux
c'est des liens bon c'est sûr que ça
peut être pas de céder
le pouvoir discrétionnaire pour moi
c'est un jeu c'est un pouvoir qui permet
de faire contrepoids au pouvoir des
fonctionnels autre critique après que la
démonstration des stratagèmes illégaux
de financement politique au parti
libéral du québec est été clairement
établie pourquoi le premier ministre
jean charest n'at-il pas été appelé à
témoigner une question qui reste sans
réponse dix ans plus tard nous compris
qu'un avait des relations certainement
dans les vélodromes avec les élus des vl
et l'attribution des contrats aux
provinces à l'on peut pas assez que
cette arrivée quoique la machine
gouvernement provincial et est plus
lourde pour l'attribution des contrats
reste que vraiment on ne laisse échapper
les gros poissons en fait c'est encore à
voir qu'est ce qui va se passer raison
l'enquète policière m'assurer est
toujours en cours à ce sujet vous n'avez
pas à décider de la pertinence des
questions on a beaucoup dit que cette
commission a coûté très cher oui senna
ou 5 millions en inde pour y est mais
l'assemblée nationale a adopté la loi
sur la récupération des sommes à qui ont
été détournés en modifier des lois et
ont créé un programme de remboursement
volontaire aux dernières nouvelles on
aurait récupéré plus de 5 millions
si on est au coin de charny et
courseulles on parle des travaux
d'excavation majeurs dont on parle le
chargement des tuyaux des services aussi
l'asphaltage les bordures de ciment donc
pour vous donner un exemple concret et
u10 soumissionnaires en 2 millions 250
mille arrondi à 3 millions 50000 donc on
parle de 800 milles de différence entre
le plus bas et le plus haut au
soumissionnaire
avec les économies réalisées au fil du
temps la ville de mascouche a pu créer
son propre service d'ingénierie c'est
l'une des retombées concrètes de la
commission charbonneau la réduction du
coût des travaux publics et
l'assainissement des relations entre
élus et entrepreneurs clar maps c'est
avantageux pour l'ensemble des citoyens
parce que ça nous permettra en plus de
travaux dans la ville